well this is marilyn monroe's dress i
tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to be able to fit this kim
kardashian went to extreme lengths to
make her 2022 met gala look work but
someone who's not impressed riverdale
star lily reinhardt i feel like a lot of
people say you should just sweep it
under the rug don't pay attention to it
but that's never really been my style
the actress went on social media to call
out kim for openly speaking about
shedding lbs fast to fit into her outfit
for the gala a dress worn by marilyn
monroe back in 1962 that couldn't be
altered due to its historic nature
[Music]
it turns out the famous gown didn't fit
kim when it arrived ahead of the big
night and she revealed to her friend
lala anthony who was hosting the vogue
live stream her plan of attack i said
give me like three weeks and i i had to
lose 16 pounds
down today to be able to fit this but i
it was such a challenge it was like a
role right i was determined so how did
kim do it she tells vogue she wore a
sauna suit twice a day ran on the
treadmill cut out carbs and sugar and
stuck to a diet of veggies and protein
kim insists quote i didn't starve myself
but i was so strict you just gotta roll
with it
which brings us back to lily who shared
her two cents on kim's drastic diet on
instagram quote to walk on a red carpet
and do an interview where you say how
starving you are because you haven't
eaten carbs in the last month all to fit
in a [ __ ] dress so wrong so
on hundreds of levels to openly admit to
starving yourself for the sake of the
met gala when you know very well that
millions of young men and women are
looking up to you and listening to your
every word the ignorance is otherworldly
disgusting
on tuesday lily doubled down on all that
tweeting about why she feels empowered
to speak her mind quote i do not say the
things that i say because i want to be
relevant or get attention i speak up
because i don't see enough people with
large platforms calling out toxic
behavior in our industry some people
will never understand where i'm coming
from and that's okay
it's a similar sentiment she echoed to
et a few years ago i find that
confidence in
knowing that i'm not pretending to be
anyone else you know it's like if
someone doesn't like me that's fine
because it's just me and i'm not
pretending to be anything else so
yeah there's nothing there's no show
that i'm putting on for anyone
and lily's unfiltered opinion on the
topic comes as no surprise the riverdale
star has openly discussed struggles with
her image many times after being body
shamed on social media in 2018 she spoke
out after finding herself at the center
of pregnancy rumors with her then
boyfriend cole sprouse at the time lily
explained why she will never stay silent
about it it did take a hit to my
self-esteem for a second and then i kind
of picked myself back up and said
i'm not going to let this
ruin my day i felt the need to say
something
and so you know no i'm i'm not pregnant
and also if i was it's kind of sad that
people felt the need to just make my
weight a topic of conversation
i mean it's but that's just the world we
live in but i'm gonna always speak out
about something that i feel i need to
talk about
[Music]
you